yes I get to see with my own eyes we
wanted to try to simplify the approach
with him Stan so he's got four different
styles that you can change on the fly
he's got different melee weapons that
you're gonna be able to change on the
fly and he's got different ranged
weapons that you're gonna be able to
change on the fly and the approach to
making that a little easier for people
lies in giving people the ability to
change their equipment load outs so they
can change the order of the weapons or
they can even say you know what I don't
want to take three or four weapons I
want to take two X maybe I want to just
take the cavalier I just want to take
rebellion and that way when I'm
switching I don't have to worry about
hitting the button multiple times to
switch to a specific weapon I know I
just hit the button once and I'm going
so it's about kind of giving people more
choice that's really the biggest
evolution for him although there are
definitely some new surprises that we
haven't announced yet there's gonna be
some pretty cool weapons
[Music]
it's not necessarily that you're looking
at Dante's characters through the
gameplay in terms of the different
styles and it's not really that there's
gonna be one style that's more Dante
like than the other in fact all the
styles are created with the idea that
okay there's different way to play is
down to it everyone can choose how they
want to play they can have their options
but the way those styles are implemented
in ways actions implement or implemented
should show his character should show
his personality and so this time around
you figure it's been several years since
devil may cry for so he's been through
he's been through even more and he's
pretty confident he's doing he's pretty
and so he's still kind of playful and
slow kind of stylish and everything he
does and that comes through in all of
his different animations in all these
different moves on the other hand you'll
have like Nero Nero he is a lot more
forceful he's a lot more direct and he's
a lot more powerful with what he's doing
is very he'll very much try to brute
force
you might compare with like Virgil from
the past you Virgil's the kind of
character that there's absolutely no
waste in anything he does
everything he does is very deliberate
and completely wasted
whereas Dante he's got the confidence
he's got the smirk and for him it's all
about style and that should come through
I was done
[Music]
dr. Chopra who nah no it really is the
idea behind the weapon even if the name
didn't necessarily come from that the
idea behind the weapon really is that
don t is very cavalier when you because
it's this way it's raw power you know
because it's it's got this engine it's
got these wheels that are turning you
know super fast and so as you noticed
when he swings the weapon because it's
so powerful there's a lot of times where
it seems like Dante's gonna be in
control it seems like he might actually
get kind of carried along with the
weapon because of how powerful it is is
how the tires are turning and everything
how it's going along the ground but he
manages to just bare it almost seems
like it's just barely he manages to have
complete control over it so it never
seems like he's losing control you know
and so it is kind of cavalier in that
regard the guy that that came up with
the idea for the weapon has been making
Devil May Cry and Dante since the first
game so you're right that he does have
this very deliberate movement and he
goes for the wind up but he swings down
you know but the the point there is
really more okay here's how you this
weapon is this is this deliberate weapon
but it's all about timing the button
press I mean button presses oh I'm gonna
make that hit and then you're going to
continue to hit with that move with the
chainsaw like multiple hits and then
release the button go on and then time
it to go on to the next move in the
combo
[Music]
you can't you can buy red orbs with real
money if you want and you'll notice we
took out like proud Souls and Demon's
before we had proud Souls
we've decided alright we make everything
purchasable and acquirable with red arms
including continues as well we're trying
to find different ways that we can give
people more options to play the game the
way they want to play
so we've balanced the game so that you
pull it through the game and you should
have quite a few red orbs left over as
you're playing through the game as
you're playing through on devil hunger
for instance but we want to get people
the after that all right look for people
that just like want a brute force it for
people just wanna I just want to like go
ahead and just like get all the moves
right off the bat or I just I just want
to go ahead and brute force it so that I
can continue as many times as I want
right away and that's really where that
thinking comes from so there's this -
there's two different things that we
think about when we set the prices of
the moves of the skills in red orbs the
first thing is the stuff that we feel
that people should want to get first
make so that people will kind of keep
doing it but then for the stuff that's
gonna be harder to use it's gonna be
harder to master we make that more
expensive partly so that okay if you
save up for that here I have you you're
not gonna be able to buy as many orbs or
you gonna be able is buy as many skills
and so you're going to you know actually
have the time to know then you have to
make that decision okay am I gonna go
for the cheaper stuff or am I going to
save up get this thing that actually
gonna have a lot of application but I
have to spend time learning with giving
people the ability to purchase red orbs
everyone like you said it's something
that we're thinking we just want to give
people the option that if they want to
brute force it if they want to save time
and they just want to get all that stuff
at once
those people can do that but on the
other hand like if we've done our jobs
right
you shouldn't have to get all the masks
you should be able to play it the way
you want to play it
we've balanced this the way we always
have and so in terms of saying something
anybody that does have fears really it's
it's a matter of we have balanced this
very much with the idea that you don't
have to spend money you shouldn't have
to spend money that's not not what
that's there for it's really there to
give people the option if to say to
people that the people that are used to
the series that have played the series
they can play through the way they
always have it's it should be balanced
the way that has always been about but
for people that they want to buy that
air hike you know like they wanted to
start off like okay I don't quite I
don't have enough Forbes so do I am I do
I want to play in all this you know 30
minutes I want to keep going to the game
and then get enough Forbes but I just
want to go ahead and get that now like
literally just okay if you want that
option you love killing me hi
you